Speaker 1: So in order to try to defend himself,
Republican Georgia Senate candidate Herschel
Walker went on Sean Hannity's Fox News program
last night. And this is all about this explosive
story we're in. Although for months and months
and months, Herschel Walker has been saying
I'm pro-life. No exceptions for rape, incest or
health of the mother. Never, never, never, ever,
ever an abortion. It's a murder. And now we have
learned that Herschel Walker allegedly paid for a
woman's abortion after urging her to get one when
she became pregnant during their relationship some
years ago. So Sean HANNITY goes into rescue mode.
And as you know, Sean HANNITY has tried to rescue
Trump in these interviews and it hasn't gone
particularly well here. Sean HANNITY tries to help
Herschel Walker and it goes really, really poorly.
Now, the funny thing about the interview is
it's almost impossible to even tell whether
Herschel Walker is denying the story because he's
so incoherent. But if you I'm kind of kidding.
Like, if you listen carefully, he does deny it.
Here he is asked by Sean HANNITY, do you know the
woman in question? And he says, I have no idea.
He has no idea whether he knows
her. And then he goes to talk
about the border. It's beyond. Charity.
Speaker 3: Start with The Daily Beast,
Herschel. I mean, serious accusations that in 2009
that you paid for an abortion. First question, do
you know the woman that is making this allegation?
Speaker 2: I have no no idea. But it is a
flat out lie.
Speaker 1: And
he has no idea whether he knows her.
Speaker 2: And now you know how important
the seed is. The seed is very important that
they would do anything to win this seat,
lie because they want to make it buy everything
else. Except what the two problems that we have
in this country is disinflation, the border wide
open crime. They don't want to talk about that.
So they're making up lies now because they need
this Georgia seat. Right. I encourage anyone out
there. Let's let them take this seat.
Speaker 1: Go, go and vote. Yeah,
that's this is the entire story really is
about the fact that Democrats want the border
wide open and this is how they're going to
achieve it. Herschel Walker then asked about
whether he sent the money and he says, I send
money to a lot of people. I just like to help
people. Then he says he doesn't really know
anything about it. And then a picture of the
signed card pops up on the screen. Every
minute element of this rescue interview
attempt just going wrong for Herschel Walker.
Speaker 2: Because right now for them
to come out with total lies.
Speaker 3: I think has to this.
So they're claiming that on September 12th
of 2009 that the woman has a receipt for an
abortion. They're claiming that five days
later, on September 17th, you send a $700
check and that you sent it in a get well card.
They get well card. It looks like it's included
with your signature on in the article. Have
you seen it and is that your signature?
Speaker 2: I haven't seen it.
Speaker 1: It's on the screen
now. Maybe he can't see the screen.
Speaker 2: You know, I can tell you,
I send out so many, get well, send out so much
of anything. But I can tell you right now.
Speaker 1: He sends out so much of anything.
Before we continue, I love how HANNITY is
like listing all the evidence begrudgingly. Yeah,
he's like, Listen, Herschel, they've got the bank
transfer receipts and they've got the get well
card and it looks like it's your handwriting. And
they also have the receipt from the abortion and
they have pictures of you on dates with the woman
and they have you in an audio recording urging
her to get an abortion. No, this stuff isn't true,
is it, Herschel? I can't possibly be true.
Speaker 2: I never asked anyone to get an
abortion. I never pay for an abortion. And it's
a lie. And I'm going to continue to fight. You
know that that's what they want. They want
this seat. But right now they've energized
me even more and they're not going to take the
seat. So they better work even harder because
they've jeopardized my kids, they've jeopardized
my family. They think they can threaten me. They
think they can scare me. Right now. All that done
is energize me more that I'm going to fight and
win this seat for the great people. All right.
Speaker 1: So anyway, not exactly great alibis
here from Herschel Walker, but a wild, wild
story and just completely failing. I mean,
listen, if you found that convincing, let
me know. It's not seeming particularly
convincing to me, but let me know if
you found it convincing. And this is
only one of two Herschel Walker
scandals in the last 24 hours.